et si léon zitrone qu'on vous parle de
la base de lancement de la mode la lune
dans les années 60 fait rêver et qu'elle
ait dit le président américain l'a
promis il enverra un homme marcher sur
la lune avant la fin de la décennie
cette conquête spatiale sera suivie dans
le monde entier et elle va influencer
toute la culture pop
le voyage dans la lune c'est le sapin de
noël des grandes personnes comment ne
pas mettre ses robes de gala pour cette
prodigieuse fête des étoiles de
nouvelles matières font alors leur
apparition dans la haute couture de
l'aluminium du métal
n'oubliez pas que tout ce qui est
argenté féminin c'est rochelle la lune
mail imprégnation culturelle ne s'arrête
pas là
la lune se dansent et se chante il nous
qui nous qui paierons la lune nous irons
girondins fois plutôt qu'une
et quand on ne reviendra on a vu là bas
et quand le lancement d'apollo 11 et
programmer la télévision française se
lâche avec des émissions de variétés
entièrement consacré à la strophe
entassement et bien vous savez que dans
moins d'un mois des hommes ont enfin
posé le pied sur la lune
et oui dès aujourd'hui la lune et d'un
autre âge il suffit pour l'atteindre
d'un très banal voyage des torts
chansons sketches tout y passe
[Musique]
et vous allez m'aider coiffer savez vous
que vous me plaisait beaucoup
nous aussi c'est curieux je ne comprends
pas ce qui se passe en moi il ya une
minute que je vous connais le terrain
est très volcanique vient à la tienne
mais pour certains cet emballement c'est
surtout une occasion de se faire de
l'argent
l'exploration l'espace et commercialiser
un voyage sur la lune peut rapporter de
l'argent
aussi bien à la publicité aux fabricants
de jouets co propriétaire de boîte de
nuit qui dessine les visages des
astronautes sur les corps des filles
nues avec de la peinture phosphorescente
effectivement les jouets à la mode dans
les années 60 sont bien évidemment des
costume d'astronaute la capsule comme si
vous y étiez
et même après le 20 juillet 1969 date du
premier pas sur la lune
certains créateurs continuer de
fantasmer
[Musique]